Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 61st episode.
61st!
Final episode of FUWAMOCO Morning of 2023!
Spooky!
Spooky?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
For those that are just joining us for the first time ever today!
Amazing.
Even though it's the end of the year, it can still be the first time.
Always a good time for firsts.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
That is hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hai.
It's the middle of the week, but it's kind of funny because it feels more like a Friday, right?
Being the final FUWAMOCO Morning of the year.
It does feel like a Friday.
But it's not!
It's not!
It's just been having lots of fun.
Well, Ruffians!
We've had some very cool things going on recently.
And well, FUWAMOCO!
I got a bit excited.
Moco-chan!
Hi!
I got excited.
Well, you know, usually we start with a Pero Sighting.
It's okay.
I'm too excited.
Can we just skip it?
No Pero Sighting.
We'll just skip Pero.
We don't need him anyways.
Ruffians.
Pikachu forgettable, Pero.
Bye, Pero.
Bye.
Skip him.
Skip.
No Pero!
Pero-chan.
Pero-tan nashi.
Well, there was one Ruffian that spotted Pero.
Let's see where he is this time.
De-den!
Wait, Pero's in the sky!
That's where Pero is.
This is Pero's room!
Hi.
Are you feeling okay?
You know, I think maybe you're just blowing things out of proportion a little bit.
Not like that.
Pero, I think probably what happened is that he probably just happened to be flying in front of the sun when you spotted him.
It's just a coincidence.
That's it.
Nothing crazy.
You know, Pero, he's been around for a while, you know, even longer than I. But he's still just a demon dog, okay?
You know, controlling the human world.
No, no, no, no, no.
No.
That's something else, okay?
As much as, you know, he would probably like that, that's not the case, you know?
No!
So, feel comfort knowing that one.
Okay, Ruffians?
Don't look directly at him.
You still have freedom, okay?
You know, it's probably a good idea in every situation, okay?
Just don't look at him at all, okay?
He's not a demon god, he's a demon dog.
Spelling is wrong, okay?
The spelling is important.
It changes the meaning, okay?
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Okay, well, finally!
To what you were excited about.
What I was excited about, yeah.
I wanted to share with you right away, Ruffians!
But!
Well... We just released...
Brand new cover song of Speed's White Love!
BAU BAU!
It was our Christmas present to you, Ruffians!
You've taken a look around?
Did you listen?
We think that this time it's quite a different song than what we've covered before previously.
So maybe you'll be able to hear a
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Even their new favorite too!
It's just so funny because it's the oldest song we've covered so far, huh?
But it's a new favorite.
But, you know, maybe even if you're not familiar with the song, you can still check it out.
We really like that song!
It's sort of a cool feeling winter song, but at the same time the melody is very sort of nostalgic and sort of...
Hi!
Hi.
Very famous song, so please check it out!
Don't pick on Moco-chan!
We haven't slept, okay?
BAU BAU!
Not just that, but there was kind of something maybe a little bit secret that happened the other day.
Secret?
Yeah.
We'll let you know.
We won't keep it a secret any longer.
No more secrets!
Ruffians.
It's just about to New Year's!
So!
There was a new voice pack release!
New Year's Holiday!
Surprise!
BAU BAU!
And this time, look!
We're participating!
That's us!
That's FUWAMOCO!
We're there!
We've been participating, but we're in the main visual there with AZKi-senpai and Okayu-senpai!
BAU BAU!
I'm very happy to be along with AZKi-senpai and Okayu-senpai.
You haven't been able to get it yet!
This time, you know, because it's New Year's, the end of the year and the start of the year, there's two voice packs.
So we hope that you'll check them out and start and end the year with us too.
Ruffians, if you're really curious too, if you head to the hololive store, you can check out samples there!
And you know, as usual, we recorded them in both English and Japanese.
We'd love if you could compare the two.
We worked really hard on them.
But we also had a lot of fun!
No pero.
You know, we're a bit sorry that, you know, it's a total of eight voice packs at once.
Yeah, if you buy both English and Japanese, that's a lot of voice packs, but also a lot of fun too.
You want a hero voice pack?
You really want ten voice packs?
Wow.
Does Pero have his own voice pack?
Not yet!
I haven't seen Ruffians making a lot of buzz about these voice packs.
BAU BAU!
Don't you want to clean up a bunch of stuff with me, huh?
And, you know, make osechi, like Japanese New Year's food.
Right?
Osechi, right?
Yeah.
Nothing about onsen trips?
No.
Right?
Right!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, on the topic of New Year's, you know, usually around the end of the year and the beginning of the year, there's a lot of exciting things happening.
And well, we have some more exciting news!
Our senpai, the brains in charge of hololive's Koyori-senpai, is holding a 24-hour stream called KONKOYO 24!
That's pretty amazing, but even more amazing is that Advent has been invited!
Advent!
It'll be our first time collabing with Koyori-senpai, so we're really excited!
Bijou and Nerissa of course will be there as well!
HONKOYO24 will be happening from the 2nd at 19 o'clock JST to the 3rd.
We hope that you'll keep your eyes up for when we'll be on Koyori-senpai's show!
It's really amazing of Koyori-senpai to do 24 hour streams.
I was wondering how does it work?
How does Koyori-senpai do that?
We really admire her strength.
I like her.
I think... FUWAMOCO, we'd like to sleep.
But we have not sleep... slept... slept yet.
We do not sleep yet.
We have not slept yet.
All the tenses.
Do you aspire to become as strong as Koyori-senpai?
Yes!
But no!
Yes and no!
Koyori-senpai is Koyori.
We're demon dogs.
Similar but different.
Different, okay.
It feels like you two are a step away from 24 hour stream.
How many streams has it been since we last slept?
Four streams.
And multiple homeworks getting done in between.
But it's been fun!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, I guess that does prove me just a step away from doing a 24-hour stream.
Don't say it like that, okay?
BAU BAU!
Also at the end of the year comes a very special event.
Ruffians, do you know what it is?
Sleep?
I guess you can sleep to the end of the year, but that's not the event.
You should sleep every day, huh?
Well, Comic Market is coming up very soon in Japan.
And you know, that means... DO-JI-SHI!
Yeah, the promised land of doujinshi.
And Ruffians, of course you remember our goal to get our paws on FUWAMOCO doujinshi, right?
Remember, right?
It was on our goalies that I debuted.
Yeah.
Well, not only is Icomochi-mama selling a FUWAMOCO book this year, but we've also been seeing some other Ruffians on Twitter that'll be selling their own FUWAMOCO books and merchandise there too.
How you seeing?
Have you seen them?
I'm so happy!
I saw her eyes.
Fuwamoco.
We took matters into our own paws.
Yeah.
And we started harassing Mane-chan.
You know, to see if they can get them for us.
Yeah, and Staff-san too.
Not just Mane-chan.
And you know what?
They agreed to pick up some things for us!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
You know what?
That's really kind of them, right?
It is really kind of them, but... Now, we're making a list!
So we want to make sure that we know what's going on.
We have our paws on the pulse.
Don't want to miss any circle.
So Ruffians, please let us know if there's a circle that will be selling FUWAMOCO books, okay?
Items, goods, merchandise on.
How should we let you know?
Tweet it out!
Yeah, use the hashtag, help FUWAMOCO.
That would be helpful.
Really helpful.
You know, we want to make sure that we know our list.
Yeah.
We send it to Mane-chan.
Okay.
But you know, even though we're being very
Persistent.
Persistent, that's a good one.
The thin box would be best. We have to be a bit choosy as well.
Persistent
Let us know if you see something of interest at the FUWAMOCO hashtag, okay?
BAU BAU!
Good point, Ruffians.
Comiket only comes twice a year.
Twice a year.
But every comiket's different, you know?
Ganbare, Mari-chan.
But it's also very exciting with the start of the year.
The start of the year!
Right away at the start of the year!
Ruffians, don't misunderstand, okay?
This is not another misunderstanding about to be born, okay?
Those things are just indie books.
Yes.
Fan books.
That's all fanzines.
Yes, those things.
We've talked about this.
We've talked about it every time.
Many, many times, but you just don't want to listen, huh?
Don't whine.
I guess they're just old dogs.
You can't teach old dogs new tricks.
Well, we'll try to get it through your school!
Don't do something cool coming up!
Because on the first day of the new year, we have new outfits for you!
New year outfits!
BAU BAU!
So it's okay, we're just being silly.
Are we done?
But it's not just us, but it's all of Advent, too!
Yeah, we're gonna be having an outfit review of me, like, all together.
Like, all together, like, one by one by one by one.
And then, Moco-chan and I together.
But then, a collab, too.
But we hope you'll join us for it!
I know we've been saying, but I'll say it again!
Okay!
Ruffians, if you have any guesses on what you think the outro might look like, please send them to us and use the hashtag #FWMCNEWYEAR!
I'm looking forward to the new year!
No fundoshi!
No fundoshi involved.
Ruffians, you know fundoshi.
I don't explain fundoshi, right?
Good.
Good, good.
BAU BAU!
Exciting stuff.
Exciting stuff!
Not to explain, not to take you.
BAU!
I sighted.
And then I remembered.
Ruffians, you remember how just a couple days ago I said, you know, that was our last big misunderstanding of the year, right?
Well... That might be another big misunderstanding that happened.
Yeah.
You know,
I guess yesterday!
Was it yesterday?
It was just yesterday, yeah.
I guess if you slept.
You know, during my super chat, me!
We announced.
Shocking.
Get ready, okay?
It's shocking.
It's a bit shocking.
Yeah.
That... FUWAMOCO... We're now gonna be apart.
We're splitting.
Splitting up.
Yeah.
You know there's now a space or a slash between the Fuwa and the Moco.
We've gone our separate ways.
Separate ways.
Yeah.
All because I called Moco-chan a kindergartner.
Did I deserve it?
Probably not.
No, absolutely didn't.
No.
But, but now, you know, there are some new viewers coming into my streams who think that it's official!
Huh?
What are you thinking, huh?
You know.
Why would you ever think that, Ruffians, okay?
We were just being silly.
Silly is a misunderstanding, you know?
FUWAMOCO is still FUWAMOCO, got it?
We were just being silly.
And you know, if we're laughing, it means that we're being silly.
It's funny.
We're having fun, okay?
That's what laughter means, okay?
It's nothing scary, nothing definite.
Ruffians, go take a look at the channel name right now.
Still FUWAMOCO, okay?
Yeah, well, Moco-chan, you gonna double check?
No, I'm good.
I know what it is.
Okay?
Yeah.
You have to use your brain a bit, okay?
We're still together.
It's not gonna change, okay?
I know.
FUWAMOCO!
Still FUWAMOCO.
And we'll be that way for many, many years.
Right, Moco-chan?
Yeah.
But don't call me a kindergartner again.
BAU BAU!
It's good to get that out of the way, Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO-chan, the end of the year is very, very, very, very, very fast approaching.
Ruffians!
Ruffians.
Listen up here now, okay?
Are your ears working?
Listen up, because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it from me, Mococo!
Good morning, Ruffians!
Good morning!
That wasn't a yawn just now, huh?
No yawning, okay?
Okay.
Ah, well.
I guess maybe one yawn is allowed, okay?
Are you still a bit sleepy?
You know, from all the yummy holiday food and maybe a bit of a lack of sleep?
Well, you know what?
Now is the time for you to relax!
You made it!
We're at the end of the year!
2023 is now coming to an end.
And it's time to say hello to a brand new 2024!
Can you believe it?
During 2023, all those difficult times.
Those times when you truly thought you couldn't do it.
When you couldn't continue on anymore.
You know what?
You did it!
You got through them!
You passed them all!
You cleared every challenge thrown in your way.
And now,
You're all ready for whatever 2024 has.
Somehow, you know, we're here at this point already.
And if you feel worried about the future in 2024, I think that's natural.
But...
I will say, there sure seems to be a lot to look forward to in 2024 as well, okay?
It may seem tough sometimes, but it's there.
For sure.
Waiting, okay?
So!
Let's continue to work hard and continue to climb up the daunting wall in front of you and let's get TOTAL VICTORY over 2024!
Okay, total victory.
KANZEN SEIHA.
Okay.
You know, some years, nobody might clear the path for you.
But, you know what?
They all grew immensely from the experience, you know, of going the way.
And we had an amazing time.
So, let's make that our goal for 2024 as well.
Ganbatte desu!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, you made me yawn a little.
Don't talk about yawning.
But I feel much more pupped up for the day, pupped up for the week.
You feel pup-talked?
I feel pup-talked.
BAU BAU!
BAU!
For our Doggie of the Day!
This is our final Doggie of the Day for the year 2023!
Final Doggie of the Day!
We have... De-den!
We have two doggies!
We have siblings!
Today's doggies and today's are Bandersnatch and Wrangler!
They're siblings that love each other lots and lots!
Really?
Brothers.
They're the best pair ever!
The best pair ever!
Definitely no violence!
Don't worry, it's not violence.
They're just playing.
Just playing.
But that's Fuwawa on the right!
I'm not Wrangler, I'm Fuwawa!
BAU BAU!
I love it.
I'm Bandersnatch.
You're Bandersnatch, yeah.
My face.
Well, how do they BAU BAU, you know?
Especially when they're play fighting.
If I'm Bandersnatch, you're... If I'm Wrangler, you're Bandersnatch.
Moco-chan Wrangler.
Like that?
You sound like you're kind of playing the piano.
No!
I'm not playing the piano!
I'm Bandersnatch.
Well, you know, family is very special.
Especially brothers and sisters.
You know, seeing a photo like this, it makes me feel all fluffy, you know?
And fuzzy.
Yeah, and I can really feel the love that they have for each other radiating out from it.
Lots of love.
You can see it right there.
Good side-eye there, huh?
Good job, Wrangler!
Good job, Bandersnatch!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
Very cute.
What was the last walk of 2023 that we went on, Ruffians?
We have... De-den!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
A rainbow!
Is it a rainbow?
Yeah!
Why did I think it was just a cloud?
No, it's a rainbow.
A rainbow that over stretches the water.
I thought it was a cloud in a shape.
A rainbow-shaped cloud?
Yeah.
No, there's clouds.
Maybe this is your last walk of the year.
Yeah, this must be right.
Or I guess you could always still take more.
There's still more days.
You should probably go on a walk.
Yay!
Great work!
We're glad that you had such a nice surprise on your walk.
BAU BAU!
It's time for our Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
Since both of you have released a good amount of song covers by now... Ah, really?
Thank you!
A good amount?
Thank you.
I'm actually happy to be told a good amount.
Yeah, yeah.
I was wondering if you both record while in each other's presence in the same room, and maybe give each other advice, or is it maybe too embarrassing?
Much love, BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
This is a good question too.
I think though that being embarrassed in front of each other while singing...
No, that's something, no.
It doesn't happen.
Yeah, if anything, you know, I feel like it's very comfy and helpful because, you know, we can give each other honest feedback and advice.
But sometimes I feel like we're a little hard on each other, too, in a good way!
In a good way, too!
Moco-chan, you can do better than that.
You know, you can listen to yourself with your ears, but it's different from somebody else listening to you with their ears, right?
Yeah, so...
And also, you know, we kind of help each other as recording engineers, too.
And that makes the process go so much faster than it would otherwise, so... Moco-chan, please always help me, okay?
Yeah.
I feel like the only frustrating part is because, you know, we know each other, so then, we'll be like, ah, you can do better, right?
So then, it can be frustrating because you're like, no, I'm doing my best!
And I'm like, no, you can do better!
I know you can!
Yeah.
Not just me, Moco-chan feels the same way, you know?
Yeah, it's the same.
And then when Moco-chan gets it on me, I'm so proud.
Yeah, you did it exactly how I said.
That was perfect!
Right?
Are you sure?
I'm not sure if... No, that was perfect.
You're done.
Yeah.
You know, we're just... We're glad that we have each other to help us, right?
A team.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
All your submissions during the past five months and...
Thank you, Ruffians!
I hope that you'll continue to want to be an important part of FUWAMOCO Morning together with us in the new year too!
Your feelings won't change, right?
I sure hope they won't.
Because you know, FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make all together.
And we'll be here waiting for you, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Please join us when you can, okay?
We look forward to more FUWAMOCO Mornings together with you in 2024!
BAU BAU!
While we'll take a look at our upcoming series here, next we have... De-den!
White Album!
It's been a while.
You've been waiting, huh?
Unfortunately, we had to kind of postpone things last week because Moco-chan, you had a bit of a migraine.
A bit of a migraine?
Not a bit of a migraine.
Yes.
It's okay because Moco-chan's feeling all better now and we can go back to White Album as a visual novel that's very very special to me.
It's pretty interesting.
To summarize it very quickly, our girlfriend is
Yuki Morikawa.
She's now a very famous idol.
And, well, things are kind of a bit rough.
And our senpai in the back there, Nina, she's kind of interested in us all of a sudden.
And then she invites us on a date.
And Ruffians wanted to go on that date.
I did not.
And now things are bad.
So we're gonna see if we can fix things.
Or we'll see how things turn out.
Fix the mess that the Ruffians got us into.
So we hope that you'll join us for White Advent tonight!
Yes!
And then we take a peek at our very, very, very busy schedule.
Get off the binoculars.
Yeah, get off the binoculars.
Ruffians, look!
Wow, there's something for every Ruffian here.
There truly is.
Yeah, but...
You know, we keep on saying this is the last FUWAMOCO Morning of the year.
It's true, it is.
But, on Friday we kinda have something a little bit different there.
It says live.
What could that be?
Maybe it's a different kind of morning show?
We hope you'll still wake up for it, okay?
BAU BAU!
Here we are at the end of the final FUWAMOCO Morning of 2023.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for being here with us every morning.
Maybe some mornings you overslept.
That's okay.
I'll forgive you, I guess.
Just this once, maybe.
Maybe again, I don't know.
It means a lot for us to be able to protect your morning and the... Morning protects your smile and your morning, maybe.
In the morning.
Protect your morning, that's not what we're here to do.
We're here to protect your smile.
If that's a happy side effect, then that's good too.
But thank you so much, Ruffians!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Saino!
BAU BAU!
Tawan!
Meanwhile.
BAU BAU!
Supervillain.
Buffet.
BAU BAU!
Zombie.
Nyampo.
BAU BAU!
Toshichan.
Postman.
BAU BAU!
Dum.
Piedrat.
BAU BAU!
Wolfhound.
Rastrophobie.
BAU BAU!
Nightwing.
Nighthawk.
BAU BAU!
Takal.
Mud Mud.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
A howl of the rest of 2020's day.
Thank you so much!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!